alors le premier regard est positif
sachant qu'on a fait plusieurs tests
avant déjà donc on a eu des tests à Noël
des tests à carnaval à carnaval on a
fait une étude auprès des des clients de
Madiana directement et c'est cette étude
qui nous a permis de de franchir le cap
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte que ça
répondait à une vraie attente et même
parfois à un vrai besoin que d'avoir des
séances décalées c'est-à-dire qui ne
commencec pas au même moment qui
commence à un intervalle de temps
différent qui permet justement de
fluidifier et qui permet d'offrir une
offre client plus intéressante dans le
sens où on offre des horaires qui
n'existaient pas avant comme l'horaire
de 18h30 maintenant à la sortie du
travail vous pouvez venir à Madian à
18h30 regarder un film et puis rentrreer
chez vous et passer la soirée en famille
c'est possible maintenant voilà
concrètement tous les films ne
commencent pas à la même heure c'est
bien cela très concrètement il y a 10
salles de cinéma à Madiana donc il y a
10 films il y a certains films qui
commencent vers 13h d'autres qui
commencent à 13h30 d'autres qui
commencent à 14h et cetera ça dépend de
la longueur des films donc c'est jamais
vraiment la même horaire la seule
contrainte c'est vraiment pour le client
de én avant de vérifier l'horaire de son
film avant de venir à madyana alors
c'est une contrainte qui euh c'est une
contrainte on en a bien conscience mais
quand on a interroger les clients pour
savoir s'ils avaient vérifié l'horaire
du film avant de venir même si nous
avions des horaires fixes on s'est rendu
compte que 70 % des clients qui venaient
à madjana savaiit le film qu'ils
allaient voir et 80 % d'entre eux
avaient vérifié l'oraire avant sur le
site internet voilà donc faut continuer
dans dans ce sens-là dans cette voie-là
pour avant de venir à Madiana vérifier
l'horaire du film voilà